the jurogan experience and there's no
like predicting
who's going to get it and who's not like
there are people who go
in and out of recovery and then one day
it clicks
my dad was like quitting stuff for my
whole life
and and and eventually got sober in jail
when i was 12
and was sober for the rest of my life he
was sober for the next
12 years until he died when i was 24
and i don't think that anyone ever
really expected him
to stop drinking you know so it's like
worth having
hope for people but also my mom didn't
argue him into finally quitting drinking
i didn't beg him into finally quitting
drinking nobody convinced him except for
like his
own misery of like losing his family and
then being in jail
you know
you you used to
party hard yeah yeah yeah
what made you um
do you think it's a genetic thing yeah i
do i think it's a genetic thing i think
that
there also can be an environmental
component you know
i i know that some things that i liked
about it were
it made me feel comfortable talking to
people
um crowds have always been kind of
draining for me large crowds especially
if it's like people i don't know
um and i felt like i could
talk to guys for the first time
when i started drinking but then i
couldn't stop drinking once i started
drinking so i would be like laid out
on a bathroom floor with the guys i
liked like stepping over me
to pay to pee you know it just got real
that's how it always went i'd feel
there'd be like a moment in the night
where i was like oh yeah i'm [ __ ]
hot and then i'd
have like throw up in my ear and be
[ __ ] pissing someone's futon
so it just was always real rough and
there was a period of time
for like years where i woke up and
started drinking and drank all day and
was a blackout drinker every night
and then i actually had a boyfriend
and i quit drinking for him
and then i started again and it just was
always like it always went back to the
same place like i tried
quitting i tried quitting
every year since i started i started
drinking pretty much daily when i was 17
and then got sober when i was 29 and
haven't had
a drink or a drug since but my bottom
wasn't when i stopped when i stopped was
just
when i was done it's an interesting
thing but my last drink was actually
just like a couple sips of a friend's
beer
and then i just was like i just
something clicked and i knew i couldn't
do it by myself
and i was willing to accept help i was
willing to do
anything i was willing to do whatever it
took and so
um i did i got help it was free
what year was this around uh january
21st 2014.
wow you know it by the day yeah
that's great i don't have like a other
than the birth of my children
in my head like that i have like that's
the day i started comedy
day i was married that kind of [ __ ] yeah
but that's a big one
i don't know when i started comedy and i
don't know when you got married but
that's my
that's my date yeah i started commie
august 27
1988 and i think back to that day
all the time because i almost pussied
out wow yeah me too
do you almost post it out yeah what
happened to you i um
called yeah i had you had to call the
comedy club ahead of time
to ask for a spot the comedy cafe in
milwaukee
i don't think it's with us any longer i
think it has passed away
but um yeah you you called ahead of time
to get a spot on the open mic
and then you could do a set for five to
seven minutes and
so i like typed my set out word for word
on the computer
practiced it in front of a full-length
mirror a million times
um and wanted to cancel but i would have
had to like cancel to cancel and i'm
not a [ __ ] so i did it and you were
drinking back then
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah they yeah um yeah i used to go
on stage blackout drunk
it i would not have any of the success
that i have right now if i hadn't
stopped drinking
because i would black out um
and yeah i i went on and i told my jokes
and
some of them hit and some of them didn't
but i got that
i got the fix i got that feeling of like
telling a joke to a room full of people
and having them laugh at it
and i've been hooked ever since how did
you remember your material if you're
black out drunk
i wasn't blackout drunk at that moment
oh
other times i don't know and sometimes i
didn't i mean i [ __ ] up a lot
you know there were times where i like
went on stage and i would repeat my
jokes that i had just said
um i would ask my friends like how my
second they'd be like you
are shit-faced you know
[Laughter]
like you're drunk it looked like you
were really drunk
you know i knew generally if i couldn't
remember it
that it probably wasn't that good um
generally
yeah generally i'm like well
but i mean that's like the difference
between then and now it's like what you
were talking about
now if you have an opportunity you make
the most of it now if i have an
opportunity i make the most of it
i show up early i'm polite and
professional
and like nobody wets their pants and i
maybe get another shot of the thing
later
you know you get to move on to like the
next level on to the next step
back then i remember in milwaukee there
was a headliner
who thought i was funny and wanted to
see if he wanted to bring me on the road
and so he got me a feature set at a show
a one-nighter and um i went and did it
and got blackout drunk
and don't remember anything he said to
me
on the ride home but i do know he never
brought me on the road with him
you know like i know i'm not on tour
with him right now
is he on tour i don't know oh
i don't know i don't think i i don't
think i've spoken to him since
maybe he'll see this and maybe he will
his name was james irvin barry
all right james urban barry he was very
nice i was very drunk
it was not his fault it's a weird thing
that genetic propensity for alcoholism
because i've seen it in people where
their parents are
drunks and they just can't [ __ ] help
it i've seen it
and some people like to think that it's
all willpower but i'm not so sure
i don't have that thing i can have a
drink or two and i can not drink for a
month it doesn't bother me
but i've seen it where like one drink
and then they get [ __ ] shark eyes
it's like plink they flip over and they
like you know gerbils you ever looking
at gerbils eyes
no i never looked at a gerbil's eyes
look in their eyes they're dead
they're dead eyes like like some people
their eyes just go
they black out they get glazed over and
they're not there anymore
oh charles not here anymore yeah charles
is gone now this [ __ ] shark boy
because their eyes just glass over yeah
i mean i was never there when it
happened but that's exactly how my
friends describe me they'd be like i
looked at you last night and you weren't
there that's exactly how they described
me it's what it seems like when
someone's blacked out
drunk catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience